pas sûr du tout départ déjà ça dépend
beaucoup des commissions merde et puis
là de la forme je fume blessés voilà
donc non feinte du tout sur les parts
mais j'étais simple dans toulon et voilà
on arrive à mener à l'arrivée donc on
est content d'avoir bouclé ce tour on a
réussi on a réussi le défi on a réussi
le challenge de ce fait un tonneau
martinique ce n'est pas une chose facile
il ya beaucoup de zones difficiles à
passer un juste déjà le rocher du
diamant la tête du diable c'est la
caravane trois zones très difficile et
on a réussi à trouver face et donc on
est content grosse de carottes difficile
et pas de doute un camp nou se retrouver
au départ de l'étape à sainte anne
à la table du diable genre ans et plus
c'est très difficile voilà évidemment il
ya une fois début mai
le moral est resté j'ai réussi à finir
finir le tour donc voilà bah bilan
positif on a on avait l'objectif d'aller
dans les communes le sensibiliser sur
parole après du dépistage du cancer
d'être présent donc on a une épouse
accueillent donc quasiment tous les
films non core os
on est content sur cet aspect là et sur
l'aspect sportif dossier donc un bilan
très positif